aj plus talk to some amazing people this
year so it was pretty hard for us to
pick our top five heroes of 2014 but
here it goes I'd be coy fish nearly met
roberto guerrero chavo muslim el chavo
cristiano Chavo lurkey atcha vodka
master ayub muhammad is a hero to the
child laborers he teaches for free in
islamabad pakistan which makes him a
hero to us
thousands marched in New York City to
demand climate change action but no one
Connor I quite like this dude dressed up
as a polar bear the polar bear actually
got arrested which only made us want to
save him more sherry hi badal mission in
san-tomás SDLP Jewish it to stay human
hamburger GTM terrible ha I'm the
Guttenberg
as a threat of Isis spread our cameras
caught these Kurdish women in Iraq
getting ready to fight back
yoona stoughton activist Freda Houston
makes our list for blockading Canadian
oil and gas pipelines on indigenous land
watching her confront a pipeline rep was
a thing of beauty so whatever we told
you that the federal government doesn't
have jurisdiction on our character we
have the final place
you
Hong Kong never end up like this good
before it's a good morning I'm here for
democracy our number one slot is a joint
award to three different groups of
protesters who challenged their
governments the Hong Kongers who staged
what was probably the most significant
demonstration since Tiananmen Square all
for democracy and the folks in Mexico
who couldn't take government collusion
with the cartels anymore and the people
in Ferguson who refused to accept the
death of yet another on our black person
Michael Brown they started a movement in
the face of a totally militarized police
force and got the world on their side
it's because of all these heroes that
we're looking forward to 2015